you
[Music]
so today I want to address issues with
AI in the open world but I thought first
I would talk to you a bit about
Microsoft Research AI so the first the
founders of the field of AI in nineteen
in 1950s laid out four pillars of the
field of AI where things really going in
the future here and over the last sixty
years these pillars have been central
themes of what we do
perception learning reasoning and
natural language and over the decades as
the field has matured numerous sub
disciplines have evolved into separate
and distinct areas of study and whole
new communities have come to the fore
and set up around these technologies
there's been a quite a bit of sharing of
technical innovations among these
communities but the opportunity to a lot
more and bring these folks together over
some key of critical and persistent
challenges now Microsoft Research in its
diversity and breadth has attracted top
talent you need to these areas and we
thought would it be better to think
through right now a new organization a
new culture arrayed around some key
aspirations just a few and I'll mention
three right now attaining more general
intelligence mastering you maniacally
beret ssin and studying insights and
leading with insights on people AI and
society let me tell you a little bit
more about a couple of these aspirations
right spread blue clear touch on where
we're going with this I'm more general
intelligence we hear the phrase
artificial general intelligence all the
time these days not clear what that
means it's probably not just one thing
but certainly we can push in a variety
of ways to get past our expertise right
now in building wedges of competence
see in some of our work with combined
natural language speech recognition
decision-making and planning and
learning into systems like the system by
my door that could do many things at
once and we've struggled with the idea
of how do you better coordinate these
competencies but there's more
opportunity and directions to do other
kinds of work to come up with new
architectures that combine some
technologies to think through fabrics
potentially using some advances in
machine learning to really address head
on the principles of more general AI
it's the reason why many of us are here
to address some of the mysteries that we
see in human intellect on mastering
unity our collaboration there's so much
upside could basically getting this
right to to coming up with principles
and thinking through possibilities how
do we aught mint and extend you in
capability often think about all the
work in cognitive psychology that's
shown us really well characterized
studies where some blind spots biasing
gaps are in our abilities can't we
leverage its work and directly and
explicitly build computational systems
that can extend the extend our abilities
in different settings over the years in
fact in the late 90s no to thousands we
did quite a bit of work on leveraging
these principles to better remind people
to understand memory landmarks through
attention and management cost of
interruption understand biases and
judgment we want to leverage that work
and it's thinking through human
cognition and machine intelligence it's
not just about color psychology there's
a lot more to be learned and to learn
from actual data sets and there's quite
a bit of design work here too how do we
design for mix of initiatives to really
get it right we think there's so much
upside into empowering people and
amplifying human ingenuity and it's on
people AI and society there are so many
T issues rising with the with the
applications coming into the world now
in trustworthiness and safety fairness
and accuracy transparency and
explanation and even more subtle but
deep explorations of the human eye
relationship but with that let me just
get it to the topic of my talk now what
did I just until you went on and our
announcement last week on MS REI given
the themes today what's up at AI in the
open world now I'm thinking too it's
more important than ever as we say
through the fruits of our Labor's as
researchers what happens when we take
our solutions that we we generate in the
laboratory and apply them in the open
world it would be healthcare or with our
agents like Cortana to understand better
how to target our goals and understand
what happens in the real world and of
course you can study different aspects
of this this gap or chasm the competency
of the systems we develop in the lab in
the real world issues of interaction
ethical legal social and societal
influences but today what did it focus a
little bit on competency I think it's an
important area and I'll get back into
the other areas at the end so from the
early days of AI especially the logic
based AI realm we had the frame problem
which is a beautiful expression of how
incomplete our systems are including the
qualification problem when I take any
action as an agent do I really know all
the preconditions are being met and what
they want might be and ramification
problem what were all the possible
effects of action right now in fact
think about people worrying about AI and
concern with a I saw about the
ramification problem would are all the
effects and influences of these systems
in the world today I like to think about
in this probabilistic AI world this idea
of getting the framing right what's the
framing of the problem the definitions
the distinctions the key actions and
purposes and goals and the overall
intention of the problem solving the
data is there sufficient data for
learning or engineering sufficient
experiences and then thinking about the
fidelity of the system both the
representational and inferential
fidelity even with infinite amounts of
data
do I have fidelity I need to be
competent in the world
whoever's talked about learning about
competency as a critical area citing
some wisdom of the ages loud C 500 600
BC somewhere in there made a very
important observation about knowledge
and wisdom saying in the towel knowing
that you do not
know is the best and pup need more
important you'll be hearing about
technologies in a few minutes he also
asserted not knowing that you do not
know is an illness the power of learning
about competency and learning
reliability models for myself goes way
back to the nineteen nineteen ninety
when I was working with contort syama
when he was a vision researcher we'll
struggling to find a good face tracker
we had three or four different versions
of face tracking all very very different
and they all fail dramatically in
different ways at different times a week
having a couple figuring out so we built
models we decided let's build a machine
learning with data sets build a model
that will actually understand the
competency at any moment based on what
we call reliability indicators for each
separate methodology we wove these
together where every single competent
every single algorithm was reporting
both the reliability and the Sigma and
the inference and it turned out when we
did this we were actually magically
surprised that the system was portfolio
of methods each reporting reliability
did very well in unmodeled situations
facing away a job did camera distraction
lights out completely it was working
beautifully which we thought wow there's
a think it's we set about building more
robust systems in the world by
developing portfolios and reasoning
deeply having each component of a
portfolio reflect about reliability
today methods for learning about
competence is very important in the
world we've done deep learning at
Microsoft Corporation now and research
about deep learning itself for example
to understand the confidence with which
captions are being generated for photos
and our PowerPoint offerings and in the
recent seeing a I worked at once and I
will say I'm not sure but I think that
might be a fence next to a farm so
reliable prediction the performance or
known on unknowns so the unknown systems
know about is very critical for even
high estate applications so I couldn't
resist buying a Tesla several years ago
and they might when I heard
pretty soon to be self-driving I said
how could I not this is my field and I
was happy in the first few minutes of
picking out checking out the new
autopilot which was downloaded by about
a year and a half ago I had it and I had
to go out so I can try it out I said wow
it's great looks oh the system knows
when it's it's not confident enough to
continue and then I I basically went
back and I grabbed my whole family and
said check this out and I went down Lake
Washington Boulevard and was looking
very reliable until the car turned into
oncoming traffic without any any sign or
any signaling at all I said okay well
you know my wife told me could never put
this thing in autopilot ever again and
make me promise
so what think about the challenge that
that the designers of automated cars
have think of all the edge conditions
things they might come over time in the
real world for me it was another another
late night encounter with barrels
closing up a lane gracefully led me to
grab the wheel and take over it wasn't
something that was programmed into the
car I wouldn't have known that ahead of
time and I've just in March of my car
was full of a bunch of exact heading to
the exact retreat at Microsoft and
here's what we encountered through my
windshield my guess is that the Tesla
designers in Fremont weren't thinking
about the rear ends of deer so I put I
took that thing out of autopilot so we
have the challenge of unknown unknown
then it's really important technical
challenge as well as a policy challenge
for AI to think through well how do we
get both unknown unknowns well there are
several ideas right we can have expanded
real-world testing clinical trials for
new technologies so you don't feel the
Tesla autopilot all at once there are
some volunteers and some ways to
indicate where those cars are on the
road maybe we do more work with
algorithm portfolios fail-safe designs
that can sort of pick up the slack if
something really fails in the end I'm
thinking about using people as Oracle's
and machines in a variety of ways now
one piece of work that captures a
direction for a certain kind of unknown
unknown blank button class classifiers
based in in training biases was pursued
by him a bin doulica raju is a
which Kawana myself last year and we
published a paper in triple AI this year
the basic idea is that we often think
about training data as being
representative and if we can build a
good model but they could be biases
systemic problems with observations that
leads to be sexual and completeness and
of course to model problems and low and
high confidence labels coming out that
are just wrong for example in the trying
to distinguish cats and dogs one
examples in our papers you can imagine
that you might be missing a whole
category like white dogs in your
training set and leading to some
misclassifications at high confidence
now it's a really fabulously the
interesting work for the direction that
appoints in we ask the question how
might we employ oracle human beings and
use algorithms to triage attention at
the blind spots to lead more optimally
identify categories of of bias and blind
spot and the methodology sort of it
basically takes a set of attributes and
lays out with set cover a set of
concepts that are clustered and let's
the system reason about optimizing the
probes by human Oracle's under bounded
resources just a direction there another
comment I want to make is yes we're in a
very data rich world right now and it's
a celebrated data rich world but we
still often face challenges with beta
scarcity for example we may have data
from one setting but was to personalize
it to a particular person or home or
build a custom tailored system for an
application that is not exactly the same
as one for which we have a lot of data
data scarcity is actually a common
problem with opportunities for AI in the
open world and several possibilities
include listen here transfer learning
learning which simulations and learning
generative models means touch on each
one of those right now with some
examples several years ago I was working
with general wins dinner wink is a
professor at U mich now with but when
she was my intern we were very stood in
this problem of predicting the risk of
infection from large-scale like
like health records which patients were
at the highest risk for coming down with
a nasty intestinal infection called C
difficile
and we employed a lot of data from a
large urban hospital Washington DC here
listed at hospital C but then and booked
a nice model and then we heard interest
from other hospitals in the same family
of hospitals not that far away in
Maryland and bulks in other places can
you can we do can we use that model in
our Hospital well turned out the
original model didn't work all that well
when you try to translate it because
these different patients prevalence sees
different covariant influences among
observations and causes and even
observational definitions would change
in fact you see the overlap there in
this little Venn diagram the symptoms
even used in the electronic health
records are different from hospital to
hospital but it turns out we didn't have
enough data in hospital a to do a good
job what can we do we go into the
literature on transfer learning and
found a multitask method that really
could be used to warp and Bend the rich
data assets in hospital C to enhance
hospital a now my sense was a lot of
what we need to do a lot more work on
this we got these to work by hook or by
crook but there's a lot of learning to
do in in the transfer learning area
another approach which is implications
for rich learning on small devices from
very small numbers of samples it's also
exciting in some ways for a model of
cognition I think it's intriguing to me
is work on taking a knife I had to ask
our PR people and our HR people that was
okay to show a knife appear clipping off
the top layer of imagenet which was
trained on a thousand on a million
photos when you had end up here now is a
system that is can generate in this cut
off layer a vector of real-world
oriented features it's learned how to
see stuff across a thousand categories
could that be used as a generic
foundation for doing lightweight
learning decision-making
from small numbers of samples and the
idea basically is we compress the spirt
we have tonight nice compression
algorithms working on what they put this
whole thing on a Raspberry Pi have very
fast-paced training so we can take a few
pictures that's like two or three
pictures of different people in a team
and have the system recognize things
right away so the approach would at the
top layer we're gonna take that vector
and instead of doing something
heavy-duty we're going to use for
example K nearest neighbor and cluster
for our learning approach to recognize
whole thing fits in the palm of a hand
I'm sure we miniaturized this is rich
carolinas device lead of lethal yet we
have two here but let me show you a
little bit about a little video here
this is rich more energetic than usual
because he's been sped up taking it for
photos of Shaam see Iqbal many of you
know that working in attention with us
and we'll see did this also as Shane
Williams over deckle Girija on a day and
now we're going to try out the system
and see how well this this this works
and we see that it's really leveraging
the rich features with little amounts of
data people putting hats on thinking the
hats off but imagine that you get a
little device that's a part of your
thermostat or your doorbell and you
train it up and it's using the powered
imagenet compressed onto that model
between light weight learning at the top
level all by way of that that knife
procedure that surgical action another
approach to dealing with scarcity of
data is is to use simulators which
simulations many successes in games of
perfect information or other gaming
scenarios are based on relatively simple
structured rules of a game even for the
games that are that are more that are
less that are not a perfect information
these systems can actually play
trillions of games with one another as I
would say with itself too and get
actually learn from that kind of
intensity of engagement which is very
difficult to do with realistic world
that's why we're often strapped one on
the same kind of power and successes
with open
world realistic human oriented settings
what might we do to to learn to optimize
action plans in submitted environment
well as many of you know back instead
worry
so tell Shah jees Kapoor gave up the wet
day and and Chris loved it got together
with others and built a rich simulator
that has incredible fidelity everything
from an physics
wind patterns weather and you can
actually fly actual live drone code to
powerup drones in these worlds and the
drones think they're actually really
flying in the world that the ancestors
especially the drone controller but even
the sensors and perception is done well
so we see what the actual in a realistic
setting what a drone sensor will
actually be seeing now the idea
basically is if we could do this might
we be able to learn in these worlds and
I'm happy to announce that we just
extended air sim to talk directly
through API is to deep learning
algorithms right now we can collect data
and learn from them your deep learning
procedure platform of choice and the
idea basically what just give you a
sense for what we're working on right
now the idea basically is can we
actually for example fly our system
around build a CNN that does lightweight
depth analysis very quickly compress it
understand the trades between different
versions of our ability to do course
vision build maps and do reinforcement
learning and do this trillions of times
to build a smart device out in the world
that might be close to what we want it
to be before it even touches the real
atmosphere flying in the in the in the
atmosphere is inside air sim it's active
work right now
another area is learning generative
models there's been some magic in our
community recently over three years
starting with I say that the
regenerative adversarial Network efforts
and other approaches to learning
expressive probabilistic generative
models from small numbers of samples
I've been very impressed by that in that
same spirit some recent work by
Sebastian Ellison and team in our
Cambridge lab was looking at just taking
a few training examples for example a
folder of pictures of the same person
with different from different views and
different lighting conditions or very
similar looking people with different in
the same kind of lighting or shading or
color and so you see they set a sense
here for the prospect of building a
latent space and having smooth control
over a latent space just for a few
samples
I believe these methods including
related methods right now on furring
generative models will be very powerful
moving forward in in how we actually
learn in semi-supervised ways I would
say unsupervised because there's a
signal here coming but it's very
lightweight also impressed by work on
not just relying on learning but
injecting what we know about the world
the physics of the world the way
lighting works in the world so work by
push me co-lead Josh Tenenbaum Tessa
spoke on me and others looked at the
idea of putting a physics engine a
graphic stimulator in the deep learning
pipeline itself and that is part of a
generative model now here's the
intuition once you have that kind of
thing you can take faces and understand
how to rotate them and shade them with
these disentangled representations right
so you can actually basically understand
the system understands well you know if
I had different illumination what would
that face look like if the human being
nodded what would that look like so I
could better recognize that like a
richer sense for a generative model of
data or a shake for
bull very very exciting work in the idea
of getting some of our physics and
causality into our generative models
directly to speed things up and that we
lie just on associations and learning so
with what I said about moving into the
open world with our technology that I
mentioned talking most about competency
right now data scarcity data morphing
how to make these these systems more
effective in the world and understand
them but coming into a world where AI
technologies are being implied applied
in high stakes settings like healthcare
and criminal justice brings to mind the
responsibility and the care we need to
scrutinize these systems when they're
out in the world there's a lot to be
done technical legal ethics in the
ethics realm and other areas and they're
growing responsibilities for us as
research scientists us as Microsoft
Corporation other companies in the wider
community to develop methods and tools
and processes that address potential
concerns a couple years ago now there
was some interesting work investigating
with Julia Angwin
and others investigating biases rising
deep in datasets for criminal justice
systems that will be used to advise
judges across the country on decisions
about bail and imprisonment and as an
article on this work showed in the Pro
Publica a venue you have folks that are
being indicated as high risk versus low
risk
I mean dug into the data seemed that
there were some systemic biases that
could be explained as observational bias
other forms of blind spot
unknown unknowns now this is a very
high-stakes almost scary situation but
even in lighter stakes settings like
Microsoft's cognitive services
we want to stick to the details of
possible biases understand methodologies
and best practices so this shows you a
demonstration of Microsoft cognitive
service that does a motion detection
that could be woven into applications
with simple calls among just like other
applications other cognitive services
and last year I Anna Howard visited us
and we decided to dive into looking at
some of the cognitive services and we
found that Microsoft's cognitive service
for emotion was failing in certain ways
on children young people looked at the
training set and it turned out the
distribution of training data was that
you might expect senator round adults we
characterize the challenges the problems
and we even show how we can generate a
contact lens almost like for the Hubble
telescope you put over the system for
children if they're being if they're
being examined by this motion detector
but it suggested that it's possible to
think about best practices for all of
our cognitive services and to share them
with the more global community as well
as policies and procedures not just
about biases but about the unknown
unknowns safety critical issues Humanite
collaboration and issues that might
arise there and deeper issues with our
relationship with AI systems as people
and so several months ago we stood up
the ether advisory panel at Microsoft
this is a ather is a-- is an acronym for
AI and ethics and engineering and
research and we put together this panel
as key leads of each division at
Microsoft of past compassionate leaders
at in those divisions working through
issues coming up for example in Windows
and in our cloud services and and in a
research area and Beyond and this panel
reports directly to Satya Nadella and
towards senior leadership team on
broader outreach we've been very
passionate about working with colleagues
across industry
starting with links to Amazon Facebook
IBM Google and deepmind an apple and
other teams and now this partnership on
I eye as we call it has grown to include
nonprofit organizations and is a
nonprofit with a balance board of
directors that balances corporate and
nonprofit NGO leadership people can get
involved with the partnership on AI by
going to partnership on AI dot org the
the group is looking for broad
participation over the next few years as
we stand up a very important set of
efforts around best practices in AI at
the intersection of AI people and
society so put my title I need to really
address key scientific foundation about
AI in the open world in some ways I see
AI in the open world as framing a
science of incompleteness in our
reasoning systems and how we grapple
with incompleteness in systematic ways
and coupling the technology with policy
and it's not just about the core science
there are engineering practices that are
framed and motivated by this work and a
lot more discussion we need to do about
AI people in society and we'll be having
a panel on the breadth of issues
tomorrow in these realms so there's much
to do I'm extremely excited about
possibilities in some ways I was telling
some folks backstage that I gave a talk
at my triple-a I presidential lecture
called open world AI in 2009 and I view
these comments now and these ideas as
kind of an update update eight years
later and it's interesting to see I
would have I would have been really
excited to see this video way back when
see where things have headed especially
in the influence and impact the
technologies are having on the real
world so it's an exciting time and I
think we have a lot of work to do as
technical leads in this community thanks
very much
[Applause]